okay so thank you so much for coming and
what an honor to start off this amazing
what will be an amazing series to honor
an amazing person and it's amazing
achievement namely big car of course and
yeah so so and thank you to Chevy for
saying nice words I told her the best
introduction is a non introduction right
need no intersection deserve no okay
deserves no introduction is also fine so
yeah our fourth office mate Sarah
McCauley so we came here 40 years ago I
still be a little earlier but the three
of us came here 40 years ago and I want
to also yeah never mind so enough of
that here our matching markets okay I
won't read the names but you can see
that they cover almost all walks of life
and it's a mess it's a collage so let's
put some order in it and the best way I
think of putting order in it is to link
them up with big scientifical
revolutions in computer science and so
here we go
these are the pre-internet markets and i
yeah yeah so matching residents hospital
students to schools kidney exchange all
low tech and then came the internet and
came the adwords market which i'll talk
about first and foremost in the stock up
work mechanical turk better match people
to jobs and match.com that actually do
the real matching that has been going on
for millennia match men and women and
then came mobile computing and then came
new markets uber lyft Airbnb and this is
a small sampling there are many many
many more many coming up all the time
and there's one here that I have not
listed anybody important one important
for you
because every hire is a one-off how
you're going to do it through a market
every hire is the one off this is the
most efficient market there is and
nobody knows what to do about it okay
so matching markets yeah so these are
different from commodity markets that
you all know about and why they are
called market it's not clear to me so I
asked an economist friend of mine who's
in this program
Federico is unique and he says I asked
him what's the definition of markets
under which matching markets would be a
market and he said there's no definition
of markets so I told them there's no
definition of algorithms and these are
like you know air and water we don't
have to define these we just consume
them so so but let me say a few things
so so here it is call it a college
admissions market and the point here is
that a student cannot buy his way or her
way into UC Irvine okay no matter how
much money sorry we are we are well hold
on hold on Elan so no matter how much
she is willing to pay normally you don't
okay she also has to be chosen okay and
Elan is true it is right sometimes we
will spend a lot of money to buy their
way in to these universities and they go
to jail right you saw that recently well
if they found out they go to jail so so
money is not a part of the equation in
these markets and so the point is that
you simply cannot choose what you want
you also have to be chosen and it's
that's what the nature of this market is
and typically there's no exchange of
money and this these markets have been
such a big force in the economy and for
social causes that a Nobel Prize was
given to Alvin Ross and lordship Lee in
2012 in economics and I'm sure if David
Gale had been alive he would have been
the third one on this list but he had
passed away a few years ago David gale
by the way was a faculty at Berkeley and
made immense contributions two of which
we'll see in this doc really immense so
that's the state of affairs of this
market these markets the important thing
for this talk is that the engine that
drives this market or these markets is
almost always picked from this goldmine
okay it's some algorithm from matching
theory and this goldmine has been active
for 200 years as far as we know the
first algorithm was pulled out of this
mind
by Carl Jacobi who did a lot of work on
determinants and if anybody works on
determinants they have to look at
permutations right and he actually came
up with this question of finding a
maximum weight permutation given weights
on the edges of the bipartite graph and
actually solved it using a primal-dual
method okay
amazing yes but if tomorrow somebody
comes up and says that you know Euclid
and Pythagoras met on the beaches of
Sicily and worked out bipartite matching
I won't be surprised because it's so
basic right you matching men and women
surely they must have imagined that this
these are things are happening right
namely Euclid and Pythagoras so but
these are you know it's a foundational
problem foundational for the theory of
algorithms matching is and we'll pull
out three fundamental problems from this
goldmine which will drive three kinds of
markets okay the first one of course is
stable matching Yale Shepley and that is
used in these markets match medical
interns to hospitals match students to
schools a second one is a maximum
matching Edmonds was the first one to
give a polynomial time algorithm for
general graph which is what we will use
for kidney exchange and the third one is
online matching for which the very first
work was
with de carp and all mesh was Ronnie who
neither of them can be here because of
Papa fest we just finished last
yesterday last night in New York so here
we have matching tenants two apartments
and uber riders together to share rides
and so on so I'm going to show you these
algorithms in action in many of these
markets so but I first want to talk
about the AdWords market which is really
like its it has had a huge impact huge
impact on all of our lives and I'll tell
you why I say that okay so it's been
called brilliant iconic unique and it's
a matching market that matches keyword
queries to advertisers in the following
way so when you type a keyword like Y ox
you get here a bunch of search results
and here you get a bunch of ads and
these are actually advertisers who are
asked Google to be placed on at this
place when somebody types Y ox and then
then there's an exchange of money in
this particular market and I'll show you
how that all works out and the point is
that the bottom line is that Google went
public at a valuation of 23 billion
today it's valued at 810 billion and
almost all of it can be ascribed to the
Adwords market okay so what's happening
here the point is Google which has
transformed our lives spends billions of
dollars on their research organizations
on their infrastructure of computing and
networking and brings us search 24/7 and
many other products like Gmail YouTube
so on okay and this market is making
that possible for all of us and in
particular for the good old investors of
Google also giving them fat profits okay
so
see how this happens and why this
happens so the the thing about Google
there are two too big revolutions they
cost one was they revolutionized search
I won't go into that and they
revolutionized advertising in the
following way so the basic question in
advertising is how does a merchant pitch
his or her ad exactly the the people who
want the product of this merger
merchants okay namely who'd be potential
customers how does you know without
placing a billboard that is shown to
millions of people and only some handful
of them will eventually buy that car you
know that's a the good old way of
advertising completely wasteful how do
you advertise in a targeted way and the
difficulty of course is we don't know
the desires of customers you know if I
knew these people want X you know I
would just show them companies that make
X and so on and so forth the the big
insight is that when somebody types a
search query in Google they're actually
revealing to Google what they're really
looking for quite often
more often than not okay whether they
are looking for and made to come and
clean their house tomorrow or they want
to get some especially good pizza or an
extra large shoe that the the shoe
stores in this town don't carry or you
know so on and so forth and there are
hundreds and millions of things that
people want on a daily basis so that
once once the this is revealed to Google
Google just auctions off these queries
to the advertisers and that's how the
match is made and the amazing part of it
is I just talked to one of my students
who's at Google yesterday to be sure
that this is the story still holds water
today in the in the day of you know
extra care about privacy and it does he
says to a first order of approximation
it does because
is happy to just look at this as a
one-off do the match and forget it
a part of its business you know two
three percent depends on collecting
people's profiles and and bombarding
them with with ads banner ads on
products that they didn't even search
for okay but that's a small part of the
business which will run away I think as
soon as people clamp down on Google to
be were more careful about privacy and
so on but the basic business is not
running away anywhere so don't worry
we'll have free Google for a long time I
think so
so again this is the picture right here
here are the the search results and here
are the ads but the question is how did
these people get chosen to be here and
in what order are they here and so on
and so forth and and in particular you
know Google is you typed by ox and boom
search results are here within seconds
these also have to be produced within
those whatever milliseconds that Google
takes to produce search results here so
the question is how do you allocate
keywords to add to advertisers as soon
as you and and and and display them
against the search results and and what
happens is that these advertisers
actually bid for specific keywords
whatever their business calls for and
Google of course would like to maximize
its revenue so give it to the highest
bidder okay and that's called an
efficient solution in economics because
the person who can use this particular
service the best has expressed their
interest by making them their bid the
highest possible so they are the ones
who are going to gonna do the maximum
good to the economy by being offered
this service and Google is also going to
make do better on its bottom line if it
gives it to the highest bidder so that's
what is one way to do it namely
dismay the if it's suppose there was
only one one slot there rather than many
slots as in why ox then then Google
would display the ad of the highest
bidder and either charge in the bid or
the second highest bid which will make
it a victory auction and then people
won't have to you know beat around the
bush to figure out what's the right bit
so that they get their bid gets accepted
okay so that's how it goes and and and
and these people have actually bid here
so y-axis of course a drug what you
expected here was was drug companies who
would be willing to pay five or ten
cents to be here and what happens is
that when you click here whatever they
bid let's say or the second highest bid
is the amount of money that goes from
this person's bank account
this business is bank account into
Google's bank account and Google just
keeps collecting those five or ten cents
but there are billions of these that
happen in a day billions and that's how
Google makes with billions it's its
revenue right now is one hundred thirty
billion a year and I'm told about a
hundred at least one hundred billion is
this this this market so a year so so I
said this should be a should be
pharmaceutical companies but what do you
see here a lawyer a lawyer a lawyer a
lawyer
what went wrong what went wrong is that
why ox had caused some people a lot of
health issues and because of that there
were major lawsuits being filed and and
these lawyers are the middlemen who want
to reap benefits from those lawsuits
make them happen positively first and
that get their big cut and for that
reason these lawyers are happy to pay as
much as fifty to a hundred dollars to be
here and if you as a good old investor
and Google just go and click here that
much money will go from this lawyers
bank account which is huge to Google's
backing out
so no loss there right no yes there's
big loss there because this is called
click fraud and that would have ruined
Google because nobody would take part in
Google's ad business but I'm told that
by now there are only six PhD is working
on an on click fraud at Google at the
entire Google to weed out these people
who just click around and and make their
competitor go bankrupt you can do that
through click fraud but but those guys
are gone now they are not allowed to
participate in Google at all so that's
how it works and this solution was being
used all the way into 2004 but there's a
major problem with this solution and the
big problem is that when you go to
Google site and create an account for
yourself
and declare your keywords and bids you
also have to declare your daily budget
because if you don't have a daily budget
then Google can keep sending you these
clicks okay keep the people can keep yes
and showing your advert advertisement
over and over and you can keep getting
clicks and and go bankrupt if you're a
small business especially right so
people don't want that the small ones
don't want that maybe for the big ones
the more advertising the better in this
form okay they don't have to sign up for
any more billboards but for small ones
they don't want to do that
and there are lots and lots of small
ones here lots and lots and lots of
small ones so this is an important
feature that that Google has to respect
the daily budget of the advertiser and
and now a big problem comes up because
all the queries are going to come in the
future
right now you have to make a decision on
the query that you have at hand and say
- which advertiser it goes okay but our
drivers have not only bid
different amounts of money but they have
bid different have different daily
budgets and so let me show you an
example to show how bad things can get
for Google
if they just send it allocate by in the
greedy way to the highest bidder so here
we have two kinds of keywords book and
CD and we have two bidders better one
who has bid $1 for each of these
keywords and bidder two has bid $0.99
for book and and he doesn't sell CDs so
he's not interested in any CD queries
coming in okay and now suppose today a
hundred book worries are going to come
in first followed by a hundred CD
queries and let's see what happens so
comes uh oops what is that oh yeah
comes a book query and who should get it
obviously better one one dollar versus
$0.99 okay
and uh 99 more come and obviously each
one goes to bitter one bitter ones oh
yeah by the way both of them have a
hundred dollars to spend today on ads so
bitter ones money is finished and now
when the CD query comes bitter one has
no money bitter two doesn't want it
wasted wasted wasted all wasted and the
total revenue to Google is a hundred
dollars whereas the right thing to do
was send all the book where is too
bitter to and CD queries too bitter one
for a revenue of $199 so almost twice as
much so you are forced into half the
revenue if you just blindly give it to
the highest bidder without looking into
daily budgets okay and half the revenue
means you know what is 130 billion
divided by two so yeah okay it's a lot
okay so so so we want to do something
about this Google wants to do something
about it it wanted to do something about
it in 2004 so actually we got this
problem from Monica Henniker who was
working at Google at that time at that
moment and and the question of course is
that we must incorporate budgets into
the solution and this is not just an
academic concern it's a bottom line
concerned
because a very large fraction of the
advertisers a budget constraint and the
the budget distribution is very heavy
tailed and it's the small advertisers
who never had an opportunity to
advertise you know before this the only
place the maid would advertises is in
the groceries corner grocery store in in
a little you know with a little notice
on a pinboard right and if somebody saw
it somebody saw it if nobody saw it
nobody saw it so these are the
advertisers that have found a in Google
a way to sell their products and and
they have to be there you know we have
to handle them carefully and the
solution most importantly oops has to be
extremely extremely light so lightweight
not not lightweight should be heavy
weight but should be light light in the
sense that it takes very little time
very little memory so that
instantaneously along with search
results you can also put down the
advertisers you that Google chooses and
this problem we solved by 2000 and we
published by 2005 even though the
solution was took a couple of months and
what we did was first of all we
simplified it throwing out all the all
the paraphernalia and getting down to
the core and then attacked it
algorithmically and then all the bells
and whistles could be thrown back in and
okay so here's the AdWords problem in a
in a simplest form there are n
advertisers let's assume their budget is
$1 each
everything can be relaxed that I'm all
the restrictions I'm imposing here can
be relaxed so each advertiser provides
bid for keywords that he's interested in
and it comes a query and Google selects
one ad and the advertiser pays his bid
rather than any second highest bid or
anything else okay for now we'll just
play with that and of course all the
queries are going to come in the future
we have no idea where they are what they
will be so we have to do online compete
to analysis everybody here knows that
and which means that we'll compare the
revenue of our online algorithm with the
best offline allocation and greedy that
I just showed you which is just give it
to the highest bidder has a competitive
ratio of exactly 1/2 I showed you an
example where it's no more than a half
ok and our algorithm on the other hand
is the following and I'm rushing because
I have so many other things to get to
but ok there'll be a questions a minute
if you see for 3 minutes ok so we'll
have three more minutes later so that's
the five minutes extra time I get for
being your classmate so so what we'll
use in our algorithm is the agents bid
and fraction of budget spent and the
whole I mean the big idea that the the
big issue here was what is the correct
trade-off between these two the bid and
the fraction of budget spent and this is
given by this very special function 1
minus e to the minus 1 minus alpha where
alpha is the fraction of budget already
spent which is 0 initially and goes up
to 1 and F goes from this 1 minus 1 over
2 all the way to 0 and so you multiply
each person each advertisers bid for
that query with the with the this
special function applied to the fraction
of current currently what is the
fraction of budget spent to get the the
adjusted bid and you give it to the
highest bidder in that sense the
advertiser who has the highest adjusted
bid and what that does is that that
people who have spent a lot of money
will will not spend now other people
will get a chance because we don't want
to if we exhaust their money completely
when they're when the queries come that
are relevant only to them
there'll be they'll be thrown out like
the CD queries in the other example and
in the worst case this does very well 1
minus 1 over E and that's optimal not
even a randomized algorithm can do
better
and the most important thing is that it
satisfies this more centrally criterion
of being simple and minimalistic all you
have to do is 1f computation one memory
slot to keep the fraction of budget
spent and that's it and a multiplication
here okay and okay so everybody will say
okay but what happened yesterday will
happen today right yes and so you have
to also look into statistical solutions
and we had a conjecture in our paper
which was settled by Nikhil Devin door
and Tom Hayes and and and some
combination of these whole things are
used in particular our solution provided
such a general framework for thinking
about budget constrained options that
Google applied it to many many of its
products not just Adwords and bid
scaling which is what I just described
maybe not using function f but in other
ways is used by just about all the
entire search in this industry today not
just Google okay now the interesting
thing is that that this solution has its
roots in in pure theory in particular
matching theory so let me show you the
matching online bipartite matching
problem that it's based on it's sort of
based on so so think of boys sitting
here and boys and girls come one at a
time and each time a girl comes you know
who she can be married to and you marry
her off with one of the boys picked
through some algorithm and irrevocably
married gone whether she likes him or
not oh no she likes him because because
they have an edge right for now she
likes him we could we couldn't do better
than that right
something happens tomorrow so so next
girl comes in and she likes these boys
and we pick another girl and a third
girl comes in and both her boys are
married off already that's because we
made a big mistake with these two if we
had married them somewhere else
the third one also would have been
married and that's called the online
bipartite matching problem and and here
together with dick carp and omission was
Ronnie we gave the first a very simple
one minus one over refactor algorithm
the algorithm is just permute the boys
randomly and as each girl comes match
her to the highest available boy rather
than keeping these arbitrarily ordered
pull with them once randomly the boys
okay so and that's optimal
no no online algorithm can do better and
this is the base case of ad AdWords
problem because all budgets are $1 and
the bids are zero or one dollar zero if
there's no edge one if there is and each
girl comes with $1 so rather each boy
has $1 boys are the advertisers and
girls are the queries so whether or not
an advertiser gets a query yeah
it's whether or not the the boy gets
married to a girl okay so then there's
an even more useful problem for our
purposes which came later be matching
where B is large and you have bids of B
dollars B can be very large sorry
budgets of B dollars but the bits are
either 0 or 1 and B is very very large
so so now ok I can talk about it as boys
and girls but it will imply that boys
are get married to be girls and girls
get married to at most one boy each ok
if you are happy to live with that in
that world what happens is that as soon
as a girl comes she looks at all the
girls boys that she could she could get
married to and among them pick the one
that has been married leaf times so far
if all of them have been married more
than B times she remains unmarried
otherwise you marry her there and again
this is optimal and and here's a
flowchart of how it was done but I must
move on to the next one so there was a
lot of work spawned by these two these
two papers in the search engine
companies ok and they employed tens of
researchers from our community algorithm
researchers and produced hundreds of
papers on all kinds of variants they
made it a pure science effort you know
we don't care whether it will be useful
in our and because they have so much
money and you don't know which one will
finally pan out and create big profits
that was great because it laid the
algorithmic foundations for what was to
come later which is new models for
matching markets and well which was
basically matching markets because all
of these online algorithms are useful in
matching markets and then even newer
models started being studied for
matching markets with temporal and
considerations because here the girl
instantaneously has to be married but no
application other and this has that
because you know when when you want to
match to uber driver riders you don't
have to make an immediate match you have
a few few minutes to match or when you
want to match renters to apartments you
know you have a time period of three
months before that rental needs to be
placed with an apartment okay
so and there are many open issues here
in particular doing the statistical
stochastic thing which was done for
Adwords so I'm gonna switch gears
because I have to talk about many more
problems and I'm gonna talk about this
table matching problem which really
started the field of matching markets
and I'm gonna go very fast over the
initial stuff well I see I'm really
really low on time but then I'll get to
some really interesting things for that
will be I mean I think you'll like it so
in this problem there are n boys and and
girls and each boy and girl has a
preference list for the other gender and
the perfect matching of course is the
pairing of boys and girls each boy to a
unique girly each girl to a unique boy
now here's an instance n is 3 and these
are the boys and these are the girls and
this is each boys reference list each
girl's preference lists and we take one
perfect matching and we see a big
problem here namely
to like a better than B because we we
are marrying one to see two to be three
to a but two likes a better than
who she's married to and girl a likes -
better than boy 3 whom she's married to
right he likes
- better than 3 - likes a better than B
so each of these - an a like each other
- their mate in this marriage so
obviously they're gonna elope and your
mass comm is gonna go belly-up you don't
want that to happen so so you want to
find a perfect matching that has no
blocking pairs of this kind right
but does this instance even have a
stable matching this is called a stable
matching doesn't even have a stable
matching yes every instance have it and
that's the corollary of the Gail Shipley
algorithm a polynomial time algorithm
that that's the easiest way I know you
can apply huge fixed-point theorem
Starkey's forum to prove this this fact
but it follows from a simple polynomial
time algorithm that everybody here knows
right everybody knows what a boy optimal
and a girl optimal marriages I hope so
cheating can girls or boys improve their
match by presenting by manipulating
their preference list okay and and
that's very important I'll show you
where it comes up in a very very big way
in applications make you have a big
question
no okay you're just happy huh everybody
is okay so lo and behold polynomial time
algorithm of Gail Shipley by itself if
boys are proposing boys cannot gain by
cheating so the boy optimal marriage
cannot be manipulated by the boys by in
their favor so if they if they give a
wrong list
they are only bound to lose okay that's
but it's boy optimal you can say why
should boys cheat well it's boy optimal
for boys as a group any one boy can be
match match to the worst girl on his
list and there are instances where a boy
will be matched to the worst girl on his
and of course he would want to improve
his his marriage by cheating but if he
cheats he's still gonna get that if he's
worse he cannot go you know into the
ocean right he'll still get that worst
girl right so so so that's amazing right
this is really a gift from
polynomial-time solvability about which
I'll say a lot more in in a moment so we
got stability and incentive compatible
incentive compatibility just means
cheating will not help and these are
very important considerations in
economics and game theory and so we can
jump into applications so the first set
of applications is medical residents to
hospitals so in the 640 s this was
decentralized then they started using
something like Gail Shipley without it
being properly Gail Shipley and then
came along Roth and he realized that
this is really Gil Shepley going on if
you make a few small changes but then as
times went on more and more women
started entering the medical field and
you know how many years it takes to
complete your your MD right and you have
no time to go out and find a date right
so you marry within the same hospital
okay so at the end of that period when
they have to find a residency the
couples have to go and find two
positions in the same city it's not the
same hospital right and and and the girl
Shepley algorithm was just gonna send
them wherever it wanted to you know make
the best match and so people stopped
using these things but if they were
married and then roth fixed it so that
it will even work for couples okay and
now it no no it's a it's a good fix
so then matching students to schools New
York City
admits about 90,000 students per year to
public schools into hundreds of schools
every year it was decentralized in
Boston they solicited ranks ranked
choices from people but they first gave
everybody so everybody was allowed to
get their first choice until the first
year I've got filled up
then everybody got their second choice
and so on the suppose III I think I
should get my first choice and I applied
to UC Berkeley and I mean this were high
schools but I don't know any high
schools in New York or Boston so suppose
huh sorry
so I applied to UC Berkeley and and and
Berkeley it doesn't take me and my
second on my lift list is Harvard and by
the time so Berkeley is is exhausted and
by the time my turns comes around to be
looked at as a sec on my second rank
Howard is also full okay and then I and
my third choice is whatever and that's
also full okay and so I have to think
you know if I'm not going to get into my
first choice
then I should list as my first choice
something lower down on my list and I
should at least get that clinch that
right rather than go to I don't know
yes that's stupid
okay no no no no sorry this is being
recorded sir we cannot talk like that so
so okay so so this is what happens okay
so so you see the importance of
incentive compatibility if your
mechanism ensured that cheating will not
help then I would there would be no
reason for me to game the system or try
to game the system right I would not
gain right and that's what happens with
the girl Shepley based algorithm you see
and and it came out of polynomial-time
solvability algorithms made a difference
okay then we go back into this table
matching goldmine and pick out some
really really amazing amazing facts and
here they are
so suppose we impose the partial order
on the set s of stable matchings where m
is bigger than M Prime if each boy is
like weakly better off in M than in M
Prime and we'll say M is a predecessor
of M prime and direct predecessor is
obvious if no M it is in between M and M
Prime and it turns out that s with this
partial order is a finite distributive
lattice that means
it has operations of meat and join and
it satisfied the usual distributive
property the meat and joint operations
distributed just like Union and
intersection distribute and any any
lattice has a top element and a bottom
element and these are the boy optima and
the girl optimal matchings and by
putting an edge here I'll I'll put on
direct predecessors so em is a direct
predecessor om prime now what question
is how do I go from M to M Prime and
there's a very very specific way to go
from M to M Prime namely apply what's
called a rotation and rotation is a
bunch of is some article of boys and
girls for some R and for some ordered
tuple where these these pairs are
married in M okay B 1 and G 1 B 2 and G
2 and so on are married in M to go to M
Prime we just rotate them once so marry
B 1 2 G 2 B 2 2 G 3 and so on if RS
chosen and R and the are tuple are
chosen in the right way then from M
we'll go to another stable matching mm
Prime and that's how you always go down
an edge from a direct predecessor to its
successor okay we'll call this rotation
row and put that name here on the edge
and it turns out that the set of
rotations are for this instance is small
it's only n square because any BG girl a
BG pair can be in at most one rotation
there are n square BG pairs and there
are efficient algorithms known for
computing R and basically using these
rotations we can go from the boy optimal
to the girl optimal marriage because
each time we apply a rotation so we
cyclically permute the matchings okay
and in fact we can go anywhere right we
can burn it like this for it like this
one with permute right we can go
anywhere in this lattice okay now there
is one canonical finite and this is
finite not infinite finite distributive
lattice which is that you take any
partial order and
elements let's say and look at the
family of closed subsets of a closed
means that they are closed under
predecessor okay and this family is
closed under Union and intersection and
then we impose this partial order on it
which is subset okay if you impose this
partial order then we get a lattice
whose meters intersection and join is
Union the top element is empty set
bottom element is a and this will say is
the lattice generated related by this
partial order pie
it's a lattice of a family of sets okay
this will be our canonical finite
distributive lattice okay
it turns out that every lattice in the
stable matching so the stable matching
families complete so close once asked
well yes stable matchings their
underlying structure is lattices but do
you get all lattices in this way through
stable matching instances so give me any
finite disturb your lattice and there is
a step stable matching instance for
which that is the lattice okay somebody
answered it I don't know who now but the
point is that the big theorem here is
birkoff's representation theorem for
finite distributive lattices and that
says that every one of these lattices
looks like the canonical lattice in the
following sense so let L be any finite
distributive lattice from coming from
any any domain could be stable matching
could be sets could be anything if it
stretch it
no if it steps okay also that and
there's always a partial order pi such
that L is isomorphic to the lattice
generated by pi in the manner that I
showed you right and in the case of
stable matching there's a lot more to be
said as you would imagine because it's
coming from the nobody knows anymore
gold mine and the gold mine says the
gold mine says that pi is defined over
the set of rotations and we know that
rotations are only n square in number so
pi is a succinct representation of the
lattice the lattice can have
exponentially many elements
exponentially
but paya has only n square elements but
it's closed sets can be exponentially
many not only that okay not only that so
the closed sets of off PI are in
one-to-one correspondence with the
stable matchings here let's say that
this closed set is correspond to some
matching M here then if I take all the
rotations here in this set s Row 1 Row 2
and so on and take any total order
that's consistent with this partial
order on set s and go using that total
order from the by optimal magic where
will I end up so I'm starting from the
by optimal matching applying all the
rotations in s in any sequence that's
consistent with the partial order here
any total order consistent with this
partial order where do you think we'll
end up here's what will happen at M the
very matching that this that corresponds
to right okay so next let's look at sub
lattices a sub lattice is a is a subset
of the lattice which is in itself a
lattice that means it has a meet and
join operation and now the problem is
that we have PI for the whole lattice
what is pi prime that that generates L
prime the sub lattice L prime we can
even talk about that all of this is
polynomial time okay so we can define
the notion of a compression what is the
compression well basically this we add a
set of edges if they are transitive
edges they don't change pi in any way if
they run in the other direction then
they create cycles if you have a cycle
then you shrink strongly connected
components like so and you get a smaller
partial order right obviously and these
are called meta rotations in our paper
and and these this PI prime is a partial
order defined on a partition of a
partition on our
okay and it generates L prime for some
compression of pi there is a PI prime
that generates L prime and the entire
theorem which is a generalization of
birkhoff's theorem which actually we had
to look for find ourselves in the
context of some polynomial time
algorithms that we were looking for for
the notion of robust stable matching and
it is this that if you take the set of
all sub lattices of L and the set of all
compressions of Pi then there's a
one-to-one correspondence between these
two sets so that if l prime corresponds
to PI prime then L prime is actually
isomorphic to the Gen the canonical
lattice generated by PI prime okay so
why am I telling you all this because
tomorrow if you find an application
where we have to find stable matchings
not one but many from different sub
lattices will do that and if it's
something else I think we'll do that
also because this gold mine is full of
polynomial time algorithms okay so we
change gears because I have I'm really
running out of time but she's going to
be lenient to me and do kidney exchange
which needs maximum matching I don't
have to define it but the point is that
if we if somebody damages both their
kidneys life is health because every
week they have to go for dialysis you
know what that means and on the other
hand everybody has two kidney so they
can give one if they are healthy enough
they can survive on one and and the
recipient can do gets one if there's
some huge compatibility issues that are
all working out what type tissue type
whatever so what happens if a donor you
know goes around sorry a recipient who
wants a kidney after great trouble finds
a donor and they are inconsistent right
that's where we create a kidney exchange
market they're incompatible so now we
find in that market another donor
recipient paired de prime R prime such
that B prime can give her kidney to R
and D can give his kidney to R Prime
and the two recipients are both happy
and the donors both lost one kidney H
but they can live on one kidney
hopefully well if they if they if they
get into a problem they can get into the
market so and this requires for opera
operations to be done at the same time
in the same hospital in adjoining
operation theatres and you can say well
why let D Prime give his kidney to our
first and the next day D can give to our
prime but no the next day D looks at our
prime and says I am NOT even giving you
my use t shirt forget about my kidney
right and then what happens then poor
our prime who went into the trouble of
finding D prime is left high and dry
right he has to look for another donor
and that's not easy so that's why they
have to be done in the same hospital in
for operation theatres and so what we
want to do is to maximize the number of
such match is made and the obvious
solution is to create a graph with
vertices being these D are pairs which
are incompatible put an edge between two
if the both the exchanges are possible
find a maximum matching and we are done
but there's another mechanism to be used
which is that if you have an algorithmic
donor and the donor that give the kidney
before dying okay because it has to be a
live kidney breathing well so then the
donor can start a change because there
there are all these donor-recipient
pairs waiting and one donor can spark
off a huge number of of completions and
in fact here's the New York Times
article where 60 lives and 30 kidneys
were involved okay so now we are
mathematicians right
we like to generalize right so we say Y
kidney only right so so al Roth came to
our wine earlier this year and we had a
nice discussion and here's the summary
of that discussion okay look at this
heart brain
clean liver also figures large
entertained stomach small intestine
what's common among them we have one of
each one of each not two so the big
thing here is that we are two kidneys
and we can live on one okay so there was
a generalization okay okay so so we
switch gears again and and now I'm going
to show you something quite amazing you
know a really great open problem that
was posed 40 years ago in this amazing
paper of two Harvard economists in
Highland High I might have misspelled it
Highland right Highland of Highland okay
Federico unique is the is the champion
on pronouncing these names but he's not
here today so so heaven is like Zach
Houser and what they said was you want
to run a matching market run it through
a pricing mechanism because pricing
message mechanism the one that we use in
our markets every day is very very
powerful okay so the central tenets
which which drives these markets of ours
is that market should operate at
equilibrium that means prices are such
that this parity between supply and
demand and it has done all kinds of good
in our society I think you know huge
amount of wealth and there's no
artificial scarcity and like Soviet
Union and so on so you know when you
have one good then this is how you find
an equilibrium but the point is that you
don't have one good you have many many
buyers with different amounts of
resources different utilities for
different goods how are you going to
make everybody happy and still get
prices prices such that there's this
parity between supply and demand and
we're gonna study one among many nice
models defined here due to a ring
fishing or a ring Fisher and the model
is like this you have a bunch of
divisible goods infinitely divisible
milk butter and bread if you can cut it
infinitely thinly and there's this buyer
that comes with a certain amount of
money and her utility is you ij4 this is
buyer I for one unit of good J this is
buyer I write you IJ is a utility she
gets from one unit of good J and her
total utility from her entire allocation
her allocation being x IJ x' is
summation of u IJ is linear in other
words sometimes economists like to talk
about concave utilities I'm gonna just
home in on linear because that makes the
most sense for our matching market now
for given prices of course she wants to
find an a bundle of goods that maximizes
her utility for the money she has and
this is true for all buyers each one
comes with their they all have you know
one dollar but but look these are this
is $1.00 this is $10 this is $100 you
don't see the number there but but they
are different amounts of dollars and
each has their own utility in their
minds okay and they all want to go buy a
Goods limited amount of good fixed
amount not limited but fixed amount of
goods and you want to price them in such
a way that even though everybody got
their optimal bundle at these prices the
whole market cleared every bit of every
good got sold
it's a divisible good every cent of
money got spent that's called a market
equilibrium and so I'm going to use this
particular formulation of a market to
explain to you the that I will just call
this HD formulation so there's n agents
a and n divisible Goods G and and we
want a mechanism that solicits
preferences from these from these
imagines in some manner like what does
Gail simply do
preference lists but if here it will be
different and allocates one good to each
agent so that the allocation is Pareto
optimal and I'm very quickly coming to
that Pareto optimal is the central
notion of optimality in economics it is
that there is no allocation such that at
least under which at least one agent is
and no agent is worse off so it's a
maximally happy allocation okay so it is
Pareto optimal and incentive compatible
so misreporting is not going to get
anywhere anybody anybody anywhere okay
we want a mechanism that will produce
allocations of this kind okay
and sorry yeah so so so the point is
that these people wanted it to formulate
it as a Martin as a market and I'm
coming to their exact formulation but
because markets give these two
properties for free we'll get these two
properties for free
we'll have Pareto optimality and
incentive compatibility if it's a large
enough market okay and here's the HD
mechanism it's really a marriage between
perfect matching and a linear Fisher
market what is it
so everybody reports their utilities
okay so you have n agents and n Goods
and these are n by the way indivisible
goods not divisible goods indivisible
goods and each guy each agent has to get
one good so it's a perfect matching it's
a matching market okay so so the
preferences are u IJ for derive by agent
I for good J and and also this is the
algorithm algorithm itself or the or the
mechanism is a is a perfect matching if
I may call it between a perfect matching
and a linear efficient market okay what
does it look like
so you you solicit people's utilities
and the setup is that the allocation to
every every agent will be probability
shares over the goods goods are
indivisible but probability shares are
infinitely divisible okay and the
expected utility of any agent will be
this sum summation of u IJ X IJ over the
whole allocation and the rest of the
setting is that each agent is given $1
the probability share of each good is
one unit okay
and each agent should be allocated
exactly one unit of probability shares
and now the rest of it is that we want
to find prices such that every agent
maximizes their expected utility and the
allocation itself is a fractional
perfect matching yeah I'm almost done a
fractional perfect matching okay and
then these people give not a randomized
rounding mechanism that's what you would
expect a deterministic rounding
mechanism such that if the allocation
found is Pareto optimal fractional
allocation then the integral one will
also be Pareto optimal lo and behold
exactly what we wanted comes out of it
missing piece and algorithm to compute
these prices and this fractional perfect
matching missing for 40 years even
though even though both ingredients have
polynomial time algorithms for future
markets we know a combinatorial
polynomial time algorithm from 2002
almost two decades ago and yet that
algorithm is still missing I believe
it's possible I believe there's a
combinatorial Rotem okay so there's
another question that arises which is
that that you know we found so such
amazing algorithms but in those gold
mines you know if we looked around a bit
around where we saw that we found that
nugget and we you know take a brush and
you know like these how do you call them
huh a pan and and who carries that sorry
the the huh archaeologist yeah like like
our girl lodges if you go in and and
look around there what do we find some
amazing mathematical fact just
underneath it underneath that algorithm
like for perfect matching what is it a
linear program that always have integral
optimal solutions what business does it
have is not an integer program it's a
linear program but it always has integer
integral optimal solutions you look at
stable matching this is amazing lattice
with amazing properties so you shouldn't
there be an amazing if this is indeed
true then we should look around there
you know
with that little pan and little brush
and look for something more okay and
what will we look for well okay first of
all what would we look for in Fisher
markets linear Fisher markets which has
this combinatorial algorithm well
there's a gem there and the gem is
something called the Eisenberg Yale
convex program okay this is a nonlinear
convex program with which with just one
objective function simultaneously
optimizes the bundle for each agent and
the dual variable for this this
constraint is equilibrium prices the
optimal solution is equilibrium
allocations okay and this program always
has a rational solution
despite this fusion non-linearity okay
so this is you know remember we talked
about a linear program that always had
integral optimal solutions this is a
nonlinear convex program which is
supposed to have you know maybe will not
transcend it may be transcendental you
know after all oh no
yeah log why not may be the optimal
solution should be transcendental not
even irrational but it always has
rational solutions if all the parameters
are rational something's wrong right so
anyway I was I always am amazed by by
these properties you know I just go
through the proof each time and this
simple thing gives you the equilibrium
for that whole business with all these
agents with their different utilities
different monies and everything so so in
my work when I was able to get
polynomial time algorithms for markets
and bargaining I would actually take
that that the Panhandle whatever it's
called in the brush and look around for
these things and I used to find always
these things and then then for a couple
of these I couldn't find them so I
stated them as conjectures I went all
out and stated them as conjecture for
two markets one over spending
constrained market one was linear
arrow-debreu market and other people
found it but in any case I defined this
notion of a rational convex program what
is that it's a nonlinear convex program
that has a rational
Ellucian with small denominators
whenever all parameters are rational
these are the gems
okay there are coming out with these
algorithms and it behaves like a linear
program the importance is that because
of it we can use a convex programming
solver if it runs in polynomial time
we'll get the exact solution because
there's no rounding error and conjecture
again there should be one of these for
the HV formulation if you took a listing
and looked around but I think this will
take a long time because I see huge
problems here huge but rational convex
programs have come about in many very
rich varieties and some people here from
Phil one of his students hurts his
students I don't know her name but she
said I think UCLA or something she also
found one of these in her own work so
anyway and there are many more questions
once you do this you can go on to arrow
W markets with where people have
endowments you can go to two-sided
markets and ok so I just want to end by
saying that with in theory we have come
up with something that we call the
algorithmic way of thinking ok how to
use algorithms to arrive at you know
fundamental facts in other sciences and
we believe that this will be the key
enabler for Sciences in this century
just the way mathematics was in the last
and certainly in economics and game
theory in quantum computing and so on we
have seen this algorithm clear way of
thinking at work and and giving you know
quite amazing results and we expect this
to go on so that's it
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]